so I'm Robert Martin from Google and I'm
joined by my friend Simon Protheroe from
Square Enix and today we're gonna be
talking about unlocking the value of
data for your games so the first half of
the talk is going to be primarily around
architecture and around simplification
and scaling of analytics for large
global games and then the second part of
the presentation will be Simon talking
about some of the really incredible
analysis that Square has been doing
around several of their games so who
went to the to the stadia announcement
yesterday or who watched it online
everybody excited about that we're very
excited to be adding another logo up
there to all the awesome consumer
services that Google is launching and
we're obviously most excited about
gaming so Google cloud in particular we
view ourselves as sort of the hub that
joins a lot of those other services
together and helps you integrate them
and bring value across all of those
different Google offerings and we have
sort of four pillars that we're very
passionate about number one is cross
platform and cross play and the way that
we accomplish that is by abstracting
away a lot of the technology so that you
can focus on games and data and
analytics and ultimately customer
experiences we also are very committed
to open source and open standards and
you'll see some of that today and that's
pretty different than what you see in
gaming solutions that you can find
elsewhere ml1 data analytics obviously a
strong area of expertise for Google and
will tap into that a little bit this
afternoon and I think that first slide
did a good job of sort of laying out
that one Google picture and all the
different ways that we can help you so
machine learning one of the really
interesting challenges about machine
learning you know everyone wants to take
their games into this realm so that they
can provide more customized experiences
so that they can more effectively
monetize their games it's really
challenging to unlock the insights from
your data with machine learning because
they're just are
many data scientists there's 21 million
of us developers but there's only about
a million data scientists worldwide and
there's only about several thousand deep
learning researchers and most of them
probably work for Google
so when you're thinking about unlocking
insights with machine learning you need
to get the infrastructure and the
technology out of the way of the data
scientists and you need to bring
developers into that type of analysis
and so if you think about traditional
data and analytics a majority of the
time is really spent supporting scaling
and tuning the infrastructure that's
necessary to process data at large scale
so you actually spend a minority of your
of your team's time focused on insights
and at Google we ran into the same
problem years ago actually as we tried
to scale up and we sort of wanted to
flip that equation on its head and have
our developers and our data scientists
spending most of their time on analysis
and insights and a minority of time
really thinking about infrastructure so
that'll sort of inform a lot of what
we're going to talk about here today so
this is google's journey through big
data processing all the way back to
about 2000 to 2004 time frame where we
invented distributed file systems and we
also invented the MapReduce algorithm so
that for us allowed us to unlock all the
consumer level data that we were that we
were collecting with all of our consumer
facing products but we very quickly
outgrew mapreduces ability to scale and
so in 2008 we invented a data processing
engine called Dremel that greatly sort
of altered the path as far as how we
built a data processing pipeline and
we're gonna dig into that today so if
you look at that center lane on the
slide that's essentially sort of
Google's journey internally to modernize
his data processing capabilities but
along the way I mentioned we're
committed to open source so we've been
surfacing a lot of that software for you
is open source API so things like Hadoop
HBase Apache drill and even tensor flow
now the really exciting part I think
about what we're doing today is that
we're surfacing not only the software as
open source but all of that
infrastructure that we're used
internally to power it as Google Cloud
and so we'll talk about that in a little
bit a little bit later so what does a
data pipeline look like on GCP what do
we mean when we've abstracted all the
infrastructure away so if you've done
data processing in sort of a Hadoop
based ecosystem you're familiar with a
lot of different programming models a
lot of different tools and a lot of
different sort of layered solutions to
try and achieve you know real-time
performance and scale when you abstract
the infrastructure away and you write
the solution from the beginning for
scale it becomes a very simple picture
so our data pipeline has three primary
components if you want to stream data
from a game you broadcast to our global
message bus which we call pub/sub think
of it as a global server list Kafka then
you need to take that data you need to
transform it into a shape that's
suitable for storage and that's what we
call data flow and data flow takes your
Java or Python code and scales it up as
high as it needs to go to process the
incoming messages from that data
pipeline and then the final sort of
storage area is bigquery and that's our
server list data warehouse and that's
what we're gonna actually focus on most
today so three very simple components
that all scale and all require zero
infrastructure management so this is
what the reference architecture for a
gaming solution looks like built on that
data pipeline so at the center of the
picture you've got bigquery which is
just a data warehouse with tables and
views like any that you're used to using
with sequel the primary difference is
how it can scale and we'll talk about
that in just a minute up at the top
you've got your game clients and your
game servers that are streaming data
over to the right and we're ingesting
that data with pub/sub transforming it
with data flow and storing it into
bigquery
now you also need to do batch ingestion
in many cases you might have log files
you might have chat transcripts that you
want to drop off of your servers or your
clients and you can pull that in in a
batch methodology through cloud storage
also using dataflow so whether you're
streaming or you're batching that your
data that you're using the same
programming model in both cases and the
same scaling model
so let's dig into bigquery a little bit
more deeply this is where things get a
little bit interesting so you know if
you know if you're familiar with
traditional architectures for processing
data you have a collection of nodes and
each node is generally responsible for
compute and for storage with bigquery
what we did is we realized that couldn't
scale because sometimes you have massive
quantities of data that you want to
store cost efficiently and other times
you have extremely complex queries that
you want to run and those two things
don't always scale together and in the
traditional model you had to scale them
together so the first thing we did when
we designed Dremel which became bigquery
is we separated compute from storage now
you might say you just broke the
fundamental rule of data processing keep
data and compute close to each other and
so we couldn't just separate compute and
storage
we had to connect them back together
with an extremely fast Network so we
actually have a petabyte scale network
that sits in between our compute and
storage which allows us to shuffle data
extremely quickly and we'll talk more
about that in just a minute so there's
some pretty exotic technology that's
powering bigquery but the interface to
it is the same sequel that you can use
and my sequel or sequel server or
Postgres whatever you're used to so we
also store the data in sort of an
interesting way so bigquery is a
relational database generally in a
relational database rows and columns of
data are stored together because we have
that pet a bit network we can take the
columns in your database and break them
apart as well and that allows us to do
some interesting things as far as how we
process the data and how we optimize the
data so we take the best of know sequel
databases and apply that architecture to
a relational database and that pet a bit
network allows us to take columns from
one table or from multiple tables that
we're joining and put them back together
very quickly so we process a lot of
sensitive data at Google think of your
Gmail documents and Drive documents and
sheets and all the metadata associated
with that
we would never store your data without
high grade encryption and so in bigquery
that same high grade encryption is
available to you each one of those
columns is actually encrypted with a
separate encryption key which is in
response also encrypted with a key
encryption key and we rotate all of
those keys for you so the encryption
piece is there but it's also abstracted
as well so you don't have to worry about
it so we've talked about kind of the
architecture of bigquery you might be
saying to yourself well this sounds
pretty cool but you know it sounds like
a lot like other things that are out
there one of the things that I want to
really communicate today is the scale of
bigquery so when you think about
bigquery this is not just a cluster
that's running in a data center bigquery
is the data center itself data our data
centers are built around the capability
to deliver data at scale so when you
create a data set in bigquery
there are actually three facilities like
this that are managing all of the data
that you're storing your data is
replicated automatically to all three of
those facilities
well you might look at that picture and
say all right Robert so there's still
just a cluster running in there right
like it's a big building but there's a
cluster and that's bigquery
I want to give you a specific example of
what I mean when I say we build our
facilities are round bigquery so
remember I mentioned that pet a bit
network a pet a bit is a million times
faster than a gigabit network how did
Google create a network that's a million
times faster than what you generally see
out there this is how so to build a pet
a bit network we took a hundred thousand
ten gig e links and combined them into a
fabric so this picture shows you a small
piece of that fabric that's in each one
of those three facilities this piece of
equipment is the length of a football
field in each one of those facilities
that's what allows us to shuffle data
back and forth at scale on petabytes
size data sets one other thing I want to
talk about briefly and then we're
actually going to get hands-on here and
take a look at what bigquery can do live
talk a little bit about machine learning
so not only has Google built
purpose-built hardware to store and
process your data we also have built
purpose-built Hardware to build train
and run inference on your machine
learning models now again why did we do
this I mean there so there GPUs out
there we have GPUs in our data centers
why go and build custom silicon to train
and run predictions the reason is simple
again it's scale we need to be able to
constantly iterate so if you've ever
used something like smart reply in Gmail
you might notice that it just seems to
get better every few weeks and it's
because we're allowed we can constantly
iterate and retrain our models because
the silicon that's built specifically
for machine learning it's the 15 to 30
times faster so faster is good but also
remember that most of our products that
are consumer facing are free so it also
needs to be cost effective so we get 30
to 80 times the operations per watt as
we would get on a GPU that means less
power consumption and less heat now how
do we do that how is it that this that
this chip is so much faster well if you
think about a GPU a GPU is designed to
perform one vector operation per clock
cycle if you think about training a
machine learning model you're working on
matrices so if you want to do a matrix
operation on a GPU you have to iterate
across every row of that matrix so
that's multiple clock cycles to
effectively perform one operation our
tensor processor units are matrix
processing so each tick of the clock we
can process an entire matrix operation
so that's how we're able to train faster
and more cost-effectively and so now I'd
like to jump into the console and we'll
take a quick look at what bigquery can
do at scale
so I just happened to have a petabyte of
data laying around and I thought we
might run a couple of sequel queries on
a petabyte while I'm up here so this
data set is is 1.09 petabytes we have a
trillion rows in this table stored and
we're gonna run a sequel query on it so
the first thing I want to do is in case
you haven't worked a big query let's
take a quick look at the structure so
bigquery is just like any relational
database you have tables that have
columns so we have a set of columns here
just like you'd have in my sequel we've
got familiar Anssi datatypes here so
very familiar when we talk about
simplifying the interface and empowering
your data scientists this is what we
mean this looks like a typical sequel
database so let's take a quick look at
the data so this is a preview here but
you can see that the data is arranged in
exactly the same way that it would be
arranged in any database that your data
scientists have been using so we're
providing a really simple interface to
some very powerful infrastructure on the
backend so that's cool that's kind of a
quick preview of what a table looks like
in bigquery let's go ahead and take a
look at what running a query looks like
let's see if I can zoom in here a little
bit so you can see this query a little
better alright so we're gonna do a
select query we're gonna do a select
query on the sales partition table again
it's a hunt it's a trillion rows we're
gonna round in some one of the columns
we're going to do a group by so we're
gonna be aggregating the data and we're
also gonna be sorting all of that data
on all trillion rows we're also gonna be
doing a search for a specific customer
key and because we don't require you to
do things like indexes in bigquery in
fact they don't even exist in bigquery
we're gonna do a full table scan on a
trillion rows when I run this query so
I'm gonna zoom out and let's go ahead
and kick this query off so I just say
run query and our query is gonna start
processing now let me give you an idea
of what's happening here so we're gonna
go and select those two tablets for
those two columns that I'm querying pull
them out of storage and
gonna shuffle them across that pet a bit
network to the compute nodes the first
thing the compute nodes are gonna do is
got two tablets that it has to decrypt
all trillion rows and each one
then we're gonna decompress the data at
about four to one so the data is gonna
get about four times as big as it was in
storage and then our worker nodes are
gonna look at the instructions in the
query and begin executing those and so
that's what's happening sort of
seamlessly as were processing this query
if I was to do a select star on this
same table it would run in about the
same amount of time because we just
scaled the workers out horizontally and
that's happening automatically so this
isn't gonna take long to run but I'm a
little bit impatient and I like to spend
my time doing productive things so let's
jump over and do something else while
we're waiting so I'm gonna show you big
queries ability to Train machine
learning models in sequel okay so if you
can see this query this is another data
set that I have and this contains birth
data for babies and we're gonna build a
model that'll allow us to predict the
birth weight of babies based on some
characteristics about those births this
could be useful for a game but you could
just as easily use the same technique to
train a player lifetime value model or a
player toxicity model same techniques so
let's take a look here the first thing
I'm going to do is just a standard query
to pull the attributes that I want to
train my model on as well as the label
that I'm trying to Train so I'm gonna
pull a few items about the birth and
then I'm gonna pull the weight standard
query now to train a machine learning
model I have a bit of additional SQL up
here that says take the output of that
query and feed it into a linear
regression okay so let's go ahead and
kick off a training job on this linear
regression model and so again the same
workflow is happening here
bigquery goes out calls the data up from
storage shuffles it across that pet a
bit network and now instead of
performing query operations those exact
same workers are adjusting weights on
all of those input variables to optimize
the performance of that linear
regression model and this should finish
up here and just
you seconds okay so we're done 27
seconds we trained a machine learning
model on four gigs of data so that's
step one training the model step two for
your data scientists is evaluating the
model right so we need to see how well
that that iteration of our model
performed maybe we need some additional
input values to be able to accurately
predict baby weight so again I'm gonna
run another sort of vanilla sequel query
here let's pull up all of the values we
fed into the training model but now with
a bit of additional sequel up here at
the top
let's ask bigquery to evaluate our model
performance on our predicted baby
weights versus the ones that are stored
in our training data set this will just
take a few seconds here okay so now what
I'm going to show you we get some nice
statistics back so our data scientists
want mean squared error and they want R
squared because that's what tells them
how well this model is performing so in
this case we've got an r-squared of
about 5% we got some work left to do to
bring in some additional data points so
that we get really nice accurate baby
weights but I've got the information
that I need immediately to make those
adjustments so the final step in
training our machine learning model is
running predictions so to run
predictions with our fully trained model
now we run a sequel query that simply
pulls up the input values to the model
and our predict function will return our
predicted baby weights so let's run that
real quick and this should only take a
few seconds here okay so we processed
four gigs of data there five seconds and
we returned 220,000 predicted baby
weights so in the amount of time that it
took for me to start up a select query
on a trillion rows we were able to train
evaluate and run predictions on a
machine learning model so this is what
we mean about getting out of the way
getting the infrastructure out of the
way of your very talented and very
scarce and in-demand folks on your team
let's go check back in
our trillion row table scam and it's
done it ran in about two and a half
minutes we processed 32 terabytes of
data on those two columns and here are
our total sales aggregated by day and
sorted for us what do you think not bad
that would take a pretty big spark
cluster to be able to do that you
probably wouldn't want to pay the bill
for it so let's jump back over to our
slides and I'd like to close by talking
a little bit about a customer that has
taken the full journey and that's King
we actually have published a white paper
with them they have taken full advantage
at scale of this infrastructure and what
I mean at scale they're processing 50
billion events per day so you might be
saying to yourself you know that stuff
is that scale is amazing but we're not
there yet what I would say to you is
everyone needs simplicity you know who
would want to have to spend their time
managing infrastructure if they didn't
have to and number to scale is coming so
mobile and console are converging the
scale of mobile data is coming to
console right and we also have hyper
casual that's a new emergent genre which
generates massive quantities of data so
you need the simplicity today and even
if you don't have the scale today
tomorrow the scale will be there and
it's coming faster than you think so at
this point I'd love to introduce I'd
love to introduce Simon from Square Enix
and he will talk about some of the
really fascinating analyses that they're
doing from the business side on their
data with bigquery thank you
[Applause]
great well thanks Robert
and thanks to Google for the opportunity
to tell you a little bit about what
we've been doing at Square Enix for the
last couple of years
hopefully Square Enix doesn't need much
of an introduction for a GDC audience in
case you're new to the industry we're
one of the leading developers and
publishers of games across the world
were known most for big triple-a
franchises such as final fantasy dragon
quest Kingdom Hearts Tomb Raider space
invaders but we actually have a very
broad portfolio of games on pretty much
any gaming platform and any business
model and that's something I want to
talk about a little bit about today
a little bit about me I joined Square in
92 well I joined idose as a small
startup in 1993 and at the time we were
six guys in a boathouse on the River
Thames about a mile upstream from Henry
the eighth's Palace at Hampton Court
things obviously changed quite a bit in
the last 25 years and I've spent most of
that time in a number of different roles
within first idles and then after it was
bought by Square Enix in a number of
different roles really looking at the
boundary between business and technology
development and where new technology
enables us to grow our business into new
markets new platforms new business
models and so on and that's how we end
up today looking at what we're doing
with big data and how we're addressing
that kind of challenge um
I happen to be the guy that standing up
here talking about this there is if not
a cast of thousands a cost of dozens of
people behind me that have contributed
to this work very little of it is
actually my hands on typing there's tiny
bits of code the guys try to keep me
away from anything to do with production
code these days but we've got a very
strong team both on the data engineering
side that have built this system on the
analytics and insights side looking at
working with the data and then working
across the company with game teams
marketing teams brand teams and so on
I'll try and mention those as we go
through but anybody I'll forget then my
huge apologies not by obeah later
so if we look at what we're doing the
big data we've got a number of
challenges both business and technical
both Square Enix and I dos have been
collecting data in a fairly determined
way for about 10 years since before a
square board idles and although we've
been collecting data in a in a you know
concerted way it hasn't been in a
particularly organized way so what we've
got is what we had is a lot of silos of
data of different kinds we had a lot of
game telemetry but that tended to be
grouped into different types of games
games developed in Japan games developed
in the West games using one technology
suite versus another some games the game
data was entirely held within the game
team others it was centralized but
really quite fragmented and then we had
a lot of other sources of data around
our customers web analytics data showing
their interaction with us across a range
of different websites the Square Enix
website but also individual game sites
and so on any interactivity with our CRM
system if you click on an email open an
email that data is logged and tracked
but again in a separate system similarly
purchase data social media interactions
rest registration data a whole bunch of
different sources of data and they were
all stored across a number of different
teams by different people using
different technologies some of it for
example was in a third party system like
Google Analytics in some cases it was in
a sequel server database in others
Oracle and others MySQL sometimes it was
sitting under some guys desk other times
it was in a data center but it was
really a pretty fragmented picture and
that led to a number of technical
challenges so about five six years ago
we started trying to pull this data
together at least the game telemetry
side of it and build what was at the
time a kind of state-of-the-art solution
for being able to analyze that data we
have a large on one large large but a
for us large on-prem Hadoop cluster in a
datacenter in Montreal um it was using
licensed software
per node and that gave us a challenge
that we didn't really have the
scalability that we wanted the to
increase the capacity of that cluster
meant adding in a whole node and that
was you know roughly $20,000 or so so it
wasn't a trivial business decision to
add a note to that cluster and that was
a pretty much a one-way skating
operation as well once we scaled up we
were committed we bought the hardware we
you know as an annual license fee for
the software so we weren't really able
to scale back down so if we weren't
convinced we were going to use that
hardware for more than you know a short
term then it was very difficult to
justify making investment in scaling um
in parallel with that so we were running
at you know most of the time we were
running at capacity with whatever the
capacity of that cluster was
occasionally we would scale it up but
we're running at capacity and it meant
the data engineering team spent all
their time spinning plates or you know
juggling firing chainsaws or something
like that
to try and keep things from falling over
they're optimizing the way in which the
data was stored making sure that we were
you know evicting old data and the
problem was that they were spending all
their time managing that cluster and
managing the data rather than actually
doing anything that was genuinely a
value to the business and also you know
that demo from Robert a min ago was
fascinating because we just couldn't do
something like that we weren't able to
you know we had data center Teta
scientists again very talented guys who
were really keen to do a lot of
experimentation with machine learning
models but we just couldn't do that we
couldn't take you know a large volume of
data and throw a thousand cause of CPU
at it over 48 hours to do some massive
training job because we just didn't have
the resources so what we wanted to do
was to kind of completely reboot our
data handling infrastructure I'm a
colleague of mine Tim Ward who heads up
the analytics and insights team I spent
a lot of time going around the whole
business speaking to pretty much every
stakeholder from all the teams across
the business all the locations various
levels of the organization and we put
together a pretty comprehensive list of
requirements and a few kind of themes
came out of that the overall top vision
that we're aiming for is what we call a
single game of you by analogy with you
know retail
companies that have single customer
views we wanted a single game of view
that gave us a holistic view of a gamers
interaction with us across everything
that we we could capture so game played
a target on a range of different formats
commercial data marketing data social
media everything but putting all of that
together and represented by a single
identity so that we knew that this
person on Facebook was that person on
our email database this player on Xbox
Live that guy on Steam this guy on
Nintendo switch so putting all of that
data together and there were a few other
sort of lower level themes that the
first is that the big driver for this
was that we needed it to be scalable in
a cost-effective way to enable us to do
that kind of business experimentation
that was difficult for us before we also
given the life cycle of a game and the
way in which our game teams worked we
wanted this to be a very flexible
solution something that we weren't
setting in stone today how that data has
to look for the next 3-5 years during
development game schema will often
change the types of data you want to
collect collect changes will also
potentially add additional sources of
data as the game is released and you've
got DLC drops and kind of continuing the
evolution of the game you will again
want to be able to flex the the data
that you're capturing and that goes for
other sources of capture as well so we
wanted to be able to augment that data
and to process it on the fly without
having to kind of you know Ted and
pipelines and rebuild them and so on and
finally pulling all of that data
together represents a huge opportunity
for us from a business perspective but
it's also obviously a pretty significant
risk the more data were bringing
together the more we're exposing
ourselves to the risks of data which was
previously anonymized becoming PII
because it's you know we're connecting
it all together and it represents a
pretty high value target so we need to
make sure that we had the internal
protections and controls around that
data and the good kind of governance
policies around it to keep our daily
protection officer kind of happy and
smiling so spoiler alert we ended up
partnering with Google Cloud
water excuse me um no big surprise there
but it wasn't a foregone conclusion and
we once we've gathered all those
requirements we then spend some time
with all the major public cloud
providers and a number of more bespoke
specialist companies that offered
solutions in some cases tailored to
games in some cases more kind of single
customer view type solutions we brought
them in we sat them down showed them our
problem and talked a little bit about
the the current challenges we faced and
asked them you know what what they could
do to help and we had a number of
different approaches some of them were
we can build this for you we've got a
professional service organization full
of experts and we can just give you a
solution to this and that's explicitly
not what we wanted um we ended up going
with Google cloud to cut long story
short
for a number of reasons as Roberts
pointed out the technology is you know
stunningly excellent on the network side
for example we as part of we build proof
of concepts proofs of concept on a
number of those platforms we obviously
there's no point in doing a proof of
concept for scalability if you're just
working with the amount of data you can
copy around in a spreadsheet so we were
using not petabytes of data but tens of
terabytes of data as a test set and
getting that data into the the vendors
kind of architecture and moving it
around was lightning fast with Google it
was really not a challenge at all it
took a couple of hours to upload the
data and then once it's in GCP it's
pretty much instant and move around with
some other vendors it took many many
hours sometimes even small number of
days and in some cases we never got
there
so just the fundamental basics of the of
the architecture knocked us out of the
park from day one um the other thing is
that for us Google felt like a good
cultural fit and I think that's probably
common to a lot of games companies we're
completely happy with guys turning up in
t-shirts and just talking tech from day
one we're actually less happy with
people turning up in smart suits and
giving us polish tales presentations
not true for every every industry but
for us the the people that we met at
Google from account management through
tech support through solutions
engineering and so on felt like a good
match for the teams that we had and the
the kind of people that we had on our
side working on this project um and
finally it felt as though this was you
know something that they were going to
help us to build rather than something
they were going to build and sell us and
that's a really important point of
course the fundamental thing that we we
build is great games and that's you know
our business lives or dies by making
fantastic games obviously but that is
becoming in over you know over time that
is becoming to be not enough um we need
to have a kind of transformational
approach to the way we handle data and
this represented a big strategic
platform for us to do that and so it was
really important that we felt that we
had ownership of that we've got some
phenomenal engineers on the team who
worked on this a couple of them are here
today but there's plenty of others back
in London LA Montreal who have worked on
this platform and we wanted to feel that
that those guys owned this platform that
understood it and that we weren't going
to be relying on third-party external
companies every time we needed changes
or something we needed to feel that this
was something that we had control of
from day one um and the other point is
that the the Google sort of platform in
general felt very integrated there are
you know other providers some of the
platform's felt a little bit disjoint
with Google we didn't feel that that was
actually a bit of a surprise the
engineering team originally I think
we're a little bit concerned when we
started looking initially at the
different providers kind of offerings
the feeling was well GCP doesn't have
enough kind of sliders and knobs we
can't really control it it's a bit of a
black box what we came to realize during
those kind of initial concept phases was
that actually that's the strength that
and a huge amount of work has gone on
behind the scenes
Robert alluded to earlier to make sure
that from our point it is a black box
that just kind of works so we've got you
know the the controls that are offered
to you as a developer are the ones you
need rather than just all the ones that
they could make available and that's
been a tremendous advantage over time
there have been a couple of occasions
where it hasn't quite be enough so for
example the previous version of dataflow
which is based on Apache beam one didn't
allow us to migrate schema on the fly so
we couldn't as data came in if the data
came in wasn't matching the schema in
bigquery we basically had to kind of
restart the pipeline and rebuild we
worked with Google on that explained the
problem they came up with solutions and
we we found that we had a solution when
data flow moved to beam two that will
allow us to migrate data on the fly
without restarting everything so there
are occasions where it's not quite
everything you need but there that
engineering led culture really made the
difference in in kind of getting us over
those hurdles but in general having
things kind of as a closed box that just
works is being tremendously useful
somebody once made the analogy one of
the the Google sales team that it's a
little bit like you know Apple consumer
products you think about the iPod when
it first came out compared to you know
mp3 players at the time lots of them
have had lots of menus and screens and
so on and suddenly Apple comes out with
something with a screen a little wheel
and that's it and it turns out to be the
most you know awesome consumer
experience and that's the right thing so
I think there's an awful lot of work
that it's easy to overlook that goes on
behind the scenes behind the scenes on
the gtp side to make sure that from a
you know consumers perspective a
consumer of the engineering services
that it's what you need so to cut a long
story short we partnered with Google we
using their reference architecture built
a solution which looks very similar to
that this is ours if you remember the
slide that Robert put up earlier this is
a very similar slide we've got live
streaming data coming in from games and
some other sources we have some on
premise some other data that's coming in
in batch so in some cases that some
games that are still sending overnight
play logs we've got other sources of
data that there are ingested daily
sometimes even less frequently than that
that date is coming in the batch data
goes straight basically into account
storage straight through data flow and
into bigquery streaming data is
published a pub/sub and then data flow
subscribes to that and captures the data
and puts it into bigquery on both sides
data flow is doing the data validation
augmentation sanitization and so on I'll
come on to a couple other things where
we use data flow as well which have been
kind of nice additional benefits that
have really helped us out of a hole with
some other problems and then within bait
data within bigquery
the data is controls in terms of access
at a project level so we have a number
of projects we have two projects
actually per game with different users
assigned to each project and then there
are other projects for things like sales
data and and general data sets that go
across everything and we're able to
control it quite a fine level who has
access to what data and what they need
it for similarly on the kind of
visualization and reporting side
obviously we've got bigquery in the
middle there we've got a number of
different users we have general business
users people who basically just need to
see KPI dashboards may be able to drill
in you know compare this month with last
month or something but they're looking
at sort of dashboard level stuff we have
been using power bi for that these days
we're using data studio for that much
more when we first started working on
this project data studio was you know
quite frankly it wasn't wasn't really
there compared to power bi it has caught
up very rapidly and we're now very
comfortable with data studio as a kind
of visualization tool the dashboarding
level
similarly for power users who need to
slice and dice data a bit more we were
using tableau we're now using looker
another Google partner which allows
people to basically do the same sort of
things they would use in tableau to be
able to slice and dice the data and do
more complex things and they can do in
data studio without having to get down
and dirty with sequel queries
and then of course we have data
scientists we've got some of them you
have got all of them we've got a few and
they are using traditional data
scientist tools we've got Jupiter
notebooks with you know Python scripts
and they are writing sequel and then we
do have you know a little bit of cloud
ml and tensorflow as well and those guys
are able to it to get access to the data
in the way that you've just seen Robert
demonstrate so one final concern I
mentioned earlier the kind of data
governance side of things remember this
has been going on over the last couple
of years and if you cast your mind back
to this time last year everybody was
very concerned about gdpr we'd actually
been on our side planning for that for
about 18 months before last May making
sure that we were prepared for you know
the additional kind of burdens that were
going to come to us we had a number of
requirements that the old system
couldn't meet in particular it was very
difficult for us to respond to a subject
access request if somebody wanted to
know from us all the data that we held
on them if you remember it's very very
fragmented with lots of people lots of
data and it was very difficult for us to
pull all of that together and return
somebody a kind of readable file with
here's all the information we have on
you it was possible but it meant a lot
of phone calls and CSV files being
copied around and no we forgot to ask
Fred in you know mighty also we could
opt out of things like email marketing
and so on but we weren't easily able to
stop collecting an individual's data and
another requirement under GPR is that
you can collect the data but you can't
processes you're not allowed to use it
for you know targeted marketing and so
on and that's something we couldn't do
before either and finally you have the
right to have data that you can prove is
incorrect amended or to ask that your
data was completely deleted and both of
those we couldn't really do the Hadoop
based approach we had before the data
was pretty much right only from our
point of view so if we'd had to remove a
user's data we would have had to copy
all but that data assuming you just said
drop the old you've just come burst
and not really operationally feasible so
we had a bunch of challenges that we had
a you know legal obligation to comply
with that our old system couldn't meet
that actually was the thing that tipped
this over the edge so the data science
team had wanted something like this in
place for a long time to make their
lives easier gdpr was the thing that
finally gave us the business driver
we're gonna have to spend some money
we're gonna have to do a bunch of work
to to get to where we need to be why not
just build a system we know that we need
and we know that we want rather than
just try and patch out the old system in
some way if we had to spend the money
anyway why not spend it in the right
place rather than just spending it
patching up an old system so the new
system all the nature is in one place
implicitly we have pointers to where it
came from so if we do need to find
additional sources for deletion or
something we can remember all the data
ends up in SUV but that's not
necessarily the only place there are
operational databases that will have
other copies and also we're able to
increase the level of governance we've
got around our data so one of the things
that we have been able to do is to
separate data which contains PII and to
provide additional views of that data
with the PII masked now some people will
read need the real raw PIR you know
imagine customer service if someone
phones up and says hey look I've paid
for this item in-game and I didn't get
it my inventory customer service needs
to actually have the PII to speak to
that person and verify they are who they
are going to their game inventory figure
out what they've got and resolve the
problem but most people don't need
actual customer data they just need to
know for example that these players are
unique or that they can do a you know
join across tables and make sure that
you know this gameplay data is matched
with that identity data without knowing
who that person actually is so the way
we did that is I mentioned that we have
two game projects two projects within
bigquery for each game what we have is
one which contains the raw data which is
very locked down and two it's very few
people have access and then we have
another which has an identical set of
schema but the
any PII columns in the original data are
represented by hashed versions of that
PII so it's unique but it's not
personally identifiable unless you know
what that hash function is and the hash
function is rotated every week
automatically so from our point of view
even if somebody takes an extract and
has a snapshot of what that mapping is
in a few days it's gonna be obsolete
so we're limiting our risk there's no
zero risk you can't you know you have to
live with some level of risk assuming
you're not going to completely distrust
everybody in your company to work with
data but we're able to manage the risk
appropriately people that need the data
have access to it people that don't need
the data were able to kind of protect
them to be honest from having to worry
too much about it so on to the results
I'm going to talk briefly about four
experiments that we've run with the data
since we started the first is targeting
some Facebook Ads for shadow of the Tomb
Raider so what we did here and this is
some phenomenal work my team worked on
the actual segmentation in the look like
audience piece the analytics and
insights team built the actual segments
the marketing team at Idols Montreal did
a fantastic job in in the creative that
will have a look at in a minute and what
we did was we identified six segments in
our - this is rise of the Tomb Raider so
the previous version of the game
previous iteration we looked at the data
that we had for gameplay
of rise of the Tomb Raider we segmented
that user base using a number of
attributes look at them in a minute and
then we had a number of different
creatives we had six 30-second TV spots
that we used we combined that with a
bunch of different copy lines as well
for a different calls to action and we
multivariate says a/b tested he is
actually multivariate testing to find
out which creatives resonated best with
which segments of the audience
so these are roughly speaking the the
six kinds of players that we identified
we've given them all kind of nicknames
veteran action junkie solver dabble a
completionist and try list there are
obviously numeric values underneath this
that we're using to produce those
segmentations it's not a straight binary
slice in three dimensions we've got
actually a number of different
attributes here there's a kind of
cluster analysis process going on some
of these are obvious we've got things
like game play and you know as a
gameplay completion percentage
completion and things like that some of
those obviously you know if you look at
these these descriptions on screen you
can tell what some of those were there
are others they're a little bit more
sophisticated so for example action
junkie takes risk frequently attempting
challenging obstacles that's one of the
measures that contributes to that none
of these are simple they're all kind of
combined measures but one of the
measures that contributes to that is
what the UK legal system calls death by
misadventure so if if Lara doesn't make
a jump or falls off a cliff edge or
drowns or you know is killed other than
by an NPC then we regard that as you
know adrenaline-fueled
you know lust for challenge or something
so that's something the percentage death
by NPC versus kind of environmental
catastrophe
is something that code codes for action
junkie so you've got those different
segments there and what we've done is
the team put together six six six
30-second spots they're not a one-to-one
match for those six segments that
happened to be six in each that's kind
of coincidence these spots I've got I'm
going to show all of them but we've got
a ten-second clip for each of them at
the moment that I'll show you things to
watch out for when you look at there's a
little caption we can say it says TV
spot on the right here that tells you
kind of what the theme of that clip is
they've also got very different music
and different feel to them so if we run
through that and then I'll talk a little
bit about it in a second do you realize
the tragedy you have induced what have I
done
because I could not stop for death he
kindly stopped for me by taking the key
you said the apocalypse emotional
so you can see we've got a number of
different clips there they've all got a
very different look and feel some are
darker some one lighter some have got
you know more upbeat music than others
there are some which have dialogue and
focus on the character or a storyline
others which focus on stunts and things
like that and the idea was to look at
the the segment's we had of the
different types of data and basically to
match those clips and figure out which
resonated better and then also as I said
earlier the the copyright did copy lines
that we had on the ads as well and
it's the one thing we couldn't get
working thanks so to cut straight to the
results we found that the segmented ads
on bet on average the segmented
campaigns performed twice as well as the
unsegmented campaign so we had some
benchmark campaigns that we'd run before
where we did rest pretty much the same
audience with the same creative but with
the same creative across the whole
audience the click-through rate was on
average about literally almost exactly
double across all of these campaigns
combined some performed even better than
that some a little bit worse than than
double but the average was double so
we're really happy with that the other
way of looking at it of course is cost
per click so we've either doubled our
click-through rate or half dollar
marketing costs or the same number of
clicks so phenomenally successful from
our point of view again this is you know
early days but the early indications of
what we were able to do with the data
that we couldn't before have been really
useful remember before we had that
siloed data we weren't able for example
to take the siloed data and match that
to Facebook data to build Facebook
audiences which we could now um next
this may not look you may not be able to
see the detail on this but basically
this is the Kingdom Hearts website
Kingdom Hearts came out earlier this
year and we had the the website user
journey there which is fairly
traditional we've got a straight landing
page and then there's a you know user
journey you can imagine going through
the history the franchise details about
this particular game and then a Buy Now
page this was built by the team in LA
did a fantastic job on the website but
what we wanted to do was try and make
sure that we were getting maximum use
out of that and again looking at the
segmenting the the audience for that
we've got sources of data for people who
were completely new to the franchise
we're starting on the landing page and
stepping through that journey is the
right thing to do we have other people
who have got a high kind of purchase
intent already
dropping them straight into the by page
is the right thing to do
but equally if you get that the wrong
way around the last thing you want to do
is take somebody who's ready to buy and
bore them by taking them through a whole
history of the franchise they already
know or for somebody who doesn't really
know much that has just heard about this
Pixar thing that we've done and wants to
you know maybe they've picked up some
marketing on the Disney side of things
and doesn't know much about the game
dropping them straight and a by now
Paige feels really abrupt so what we did
was look at the sources of the traffic
analyze previous kind of right route
results from those sources and then have
the basically the consumer dropped into
that user journey from those ads what we
felt was the right place for them and
this performed even better than the Tomb
Raider campaign we got click-through
rates increased by 144 percent here
click throughs to to retailer links and
overall conversion increased by twenty
percent so again really happy with the
results from that site um a couple of
others I'll touch on very briefly before
we talk about next steps we with life is
strange too episodic game we localized
into a lot more languages than we did
for life is strange one life is strange
too we saw that we had users in new
markets like Russia and so on but the
game itself wasn't localized into those
languages so for two we localized into
those languages what we wanted to do is
measure the effectiveness the
effectiveness of that we can't
necessarily just look at sales data and
say we said I'll double the number of
units we need to look at other data as
well
user data where people are playing the
game correlating that with purchase
because obviously there will be you know
in different markets other than there
are sources of you know gameplay other
than people just buying their own copy
there's lots of second-hand there's
piracy and so on as well so
understanding that helped us really
figure out how we were going to optimize
our marketing our asourian localization
spends in future um so we'll be having
done this what we've found is that that
localization
effort having analyzed the data using
the data in bigquery we can find that
we've got in some countries double the
share of users for this version than we
had it previously so that share not
absolutely numbers so the indication
there is that localizing to those
languages has really had an impact on
increasing take-up in those countries
and finally timing analysis for episodic
games this is something that we're doing
at the moment that works ongoing but
what we're trying to do is look at
improving our sales forecasting and
eventually get to the point where we can
actually control our sales curve to some
extent by affecting the timing of
episodic releases for some game some
players will be super excited about a
game and pre-order at you know release
for other games they may play the first
episode and then buy a season pass to
enjoy the rest once they sort of bought
in they're treating the first episode is
a kind of you know trial um
player see they're maybe those people
are buying a collector's edition at the
end or perhaps they've you know maybe
they've played the whole game if they
haven't but they they're buying much
later in the sequence but then you've
got potentially player D which is a
group we didn't get at all who maybe
played the initial free first episode
and then just dropped out of the process
entirely so understanding what that
looks like how those those player bases
segment out and how the timing of those
releases affect that it's something
we're doing at the moment in order to
improve not only our forecasting in the
short term but long term the ability to
actually control that that sales
pipeline so some basic examples there I
think as we've said we've now got to a
situation where there's a lot more
experimentation going on with all those
constraints that we mentioned earlier
have gone away we've been really happy
with the results that we've got from the
platform we've got a really solid
relationship with the the GCP team where
we feel we're getting a lot of support
where we need it and you know fantastic
tech to build on we have worked on a
number of the challenges that we had for
example the the schema migration
and got great results there we have a
happy smiling DPO I would have shown you
a picture but that's PII and I'm not
allowed to do it without written consent
so but we're comfortable now that we're
a lot more secure than we were in our
kind of governance around the data and
this is the first real cloud native
application that we've built
we had infrastructure in public cloud
before we had web servers deployed on
kubernetes in different environments but
we hadn't really taken a leap and built
anything cloud native what we were doing
really is is infrastructure as a service
so it was effectively just not paying
for the hard way
capex but this is you know the first
time that we've really got into that and
it's been incredibly successful so
what's next for us in terms of the
single game of view platform well to
torture the Pokemon analogy we've got
some legendary data sources that we
still wanna catch there are some games
which aren't yet in this system for
various reasons and we're you know
having got these initial proof points
we're now able to kind of bring some of
those data sources in and open up those
conversations um a year in we've also
got some good use cases where we can
justify automating or building further
tooling around the platform so things
like we mentioned earlier the ability to
filter users and to either capture or
not capture data or to process or not
process data and having that process
automated and API driven is something
that we're working on at the moment
we're looking at a cost cross-platform
segmentation framework so the sort of
segmentation that we did for Tomb Raider
we're able to have those segments at the
moment those segments are kind of
extracted out and then used to build
audience lists for Facebook and so on
with the cross-platform segmentation
framework what we are intending to do is
have the segmentations native to the
system itself so that we can pass them
around as kind of first-class objects
within the architecture and finally the
all the examples I've given here have
been sort of marketing related or maybe
sales analysis related the reason for
that is
there's twofold first of all my team's
responsible for most of those websites
and stores and so on so it's within our
team's ability to do those controls we
work very closely the analytics team and
between the two of us were able to do
this without too much additional kind of
buy-in but the other thing obviously is
that the dev cycle on a marketing
campaign is weeks or months at most the
dev cycle on a game is months or years
and so it was gonna be much quicker for
us to get those kind of proof points by
working on marketing campaigns to show
the idea the kind of proof of concept of
what we want to do with user data and
segmentation but the next step for us is
then closing that loop and starting to
use that data from bigquery natively in
games to do personalization and so on
within the game itself rather than
outside the game and what's next so
that's what's next for the the sgv
platform what's next for Square Enix in
general well we are deploying game
servers on gtp for some multiplayer
titles coming up which is gonna generate
a lot of data we are also deploying a
lot of the back-end services or identity
systems billing systems store sales and
so on are being deployed in GCP as well
again it's going to generate a lot of
data excuse me
and finally we're scaling up analytics
pipeline the SUV platform itself to be
able to cope with much larger portions
of data unfortunately of those three
pillars that's the easiest for us
because that's something that pretty
much is handled entirely by Google so
the scaling side of it is something that
is no longer a big challenge for us we
just have to write slightly bigger check
that's fine and that's it I don't think
we have time for questions I've left my
email address there feel free to get in
touch if you've got any questions or
come up afterwards but otherwise thank
you very much
[Applause]